how concerned should we be about the new
indian variant we know the prime
minister's anxious about it we know
there is a rise
in cases albeit from quite low levels at
the moment but let's just have a look at
some of the hot spots
around the country i should say here
we're talking about the variant b
1.61 it's one of the three uh indian
variants that the government
is concerned about and have a look at um
bolton in bolton there are quite a few
cases compared with the rest of the
country like i say low levels but come
over the rest of the country 47
in the past fortnight but have a look
beneath that data and you see something
quite interesting what we're going to
look at
is case numbers and specifically cases
per 100 000 of the population
by age so we're looking here under 60s
and you can see there has been a big
uptick a lot of people think that is
down
to this new variant but now have a look
at those who are
over 60. look at that very different
isn't it it's not rising as fast really
not writing at all
suggesting maybe those vaccinations are
protecting
against that indian variant let's have a
look too at another part of the country
just next door blackburn with darwin
20 cases in the past fortnight similar
thing we'll look at those
cases by age group you can see here
they're not rising as fast for the under
60s but they are potentially starting to
go up a bit maybe that's the indian
variant we don't really know for sure
but have a look at over 60s again there
is a gap opening up
so if you are seeing that that is
potentially quite encouraging
that there is a gap a vaccination effect
opening up between those two
lines suggesting that potentially the
vaccines are protecting
against this new variant and when you
look across the population as a whole
vaccinations are increasing look at this
this shows you antibodies
uh in england and they are rising very
sharply up to about 80 percent
of the population same things uh for
first doses of vaccinations antibodies
could be from having got the disease
before
uh as well and then fully vaccinated
people now up to about kind of 30
percent
of the population according to these ons
statistics that's really encouraging
particularly if you believe and the
numbers suggest that it might well be
the case
that those vaccinations do give some
protection against this new variant